Il m'a fait lui tirer dessus
il n’arrêtait pas de dire que je n'était pas réel
c'était presque comme si il était ....
des personnes différentes
Tu as raison , il peut parfois devenir une personne différente
Tu es réveillé
Qu'est ce que je fais ici ?
Tu ne te rappelle pas
Dark army s'est retournée contre nous, je pense que je suis la prochaine
L'étape 2 n'a jamais été annulée
C'était ... Lui
5 : 09
Fsociety
Je suis l'architecte
y'a toujours beaucoup de boulot à faire
Je peux arrêter ça
Non, non, non
Tu tires sur la corde (du parachute) maintenant et ils auront gagné
les catastrophes mondiales comme celle-ci
ont lieu car des hommes comme moi
les autorisent
Quelque chose est en train de se passer. Ça pourrait être important
Cela va marquer la fin de E-corp
C'est ton moment
tu ne peux plus te défiler maintenant
Si tu tire sur le bon fil une marionnette dansera n'importe où tu le désire
Dark army a besoin de savoir ce qu'il fait
Tu comprends les conséquences
C'est une terroriste
Des personnes vont mourir !
Si nous ne faisons rien,
il n'y aura aucun moyen d'en revenir